in indonesia's east nusa tenggara
rescue efforts are underway after flash
floods and landslides
in this village police and soldiers
tried to pull people to safety
in my village the water is higher than
my head it has not yet subsided
many say their loved ones are still
missing
adenara in east flores was the worst hit
a tropical low system is causing heavy
rain
strong winds and choppy seas in the area
adding to the challenge of getting
rescuers and essentials to the island
in west timor hundreds are in evacuation
centers
my house is by the sea the water rose up
and entered our house
everything is ruined everything flooded
so we took refuge here
authorities say many houses were damaged
we will continue evacuation for the
affected people security forces are
working together with volunteers
after we identify victims we will work
with a health agency to conduct funerals
president joko widodo has urged people
to be on their guard
i ask people to follow the instructions
of field offices
stay alert for floods and landslides
because of the high intensity of extreme
rains
indonesia's neighbor east timor was also
badly hit
and the disaster could have an impact on
its efforts to fight culvert 19.
unicef chartered flight has arrived in
delhi at one o'clock dilly time today
uh with the first 24 000 cover 19
vaccines
um just the uh the challenge now will be
how to
roll out the vaccination with the damage
to infrastructure
as authorities in both countries work to
get a sense of the scale of the
destruction
there are fears the environmental
disaster will deepen an ongoing health
crisis
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta